there was always a a magnifying glass on
me you have to live up to a certain
standard so I kept a lot of myself
suppressed and I quieted my own voice
and I went along to get along was there
a moment where you realized I'm gonna do
this on my own terms and it's going to
be okay ooh the choice to move to New
York City
I found this at a jewelry accessory shop
here in New York it reminded me of a
ring that my grandmother had
she had a birthstone ring with all of
her children as a kid I would always
just like be on her lap and just
admiring it and she passed away
literally the day after I moved to New
York City that woman was so effective in
loving me purely and just being a
support in my life and so with me pretty
much everywhere all the time wherever I
am just as a reminder to ground me in
faith in love in trust in in believing
in myself
there was a Sunday morning where I was
getting ready for a matinee and my dad
was getting ready for church we were
FaceTiming he was like oh no wonder you
turned into this character you know you
put all of this on and you become this
person and he said go out there and
minister to the people
because he understood the effectiveness
of what I was doing to make someone
think a little differently to see the
world a little bigger than they saw it
before they came in the theater that's
got to be a big moment for you to hear
that from your father for sure from this
person who when I came out to them said
I don't know what I did wrong and where
this has come from but I'm grateful he's
always said you're a part of me you
represent me I love you I've allowed him
the space and the grace to grow at his
time and not tried to rush it I'm not
trying to force anything on you but just
understand that my existence is my own
and yours is your own and the two can
mutually exist and be just fine we were
in a time where everybody's talking
about pronouns you prefer they them I
prefer all things with respect you care
about respect yes because I don't expect
you to fully understand no matter how I
am presenting to you what I feel and who
I am and at any given moment that could
be anything I have feminine power I have
masculine power people will
conditionally respond to what they see I
give people the permission to call me
all things all things with respect is
that an important evolution in the
discussion we're having to be accepting
of those just getting used to this
process in this whole new world
absolutely understanding that some
people are going to get it wrong but
they're not intending to to hurt or
diminish someone yeah absolutely we live
in society where we have to put a label
on it so that we can make sense of it
but your he him is a different he him
than somebody else is
my they them is a different than
somebody else's
[Music]
foreign
that's dated material it doesn't speak
to our time do you like those
expectations coming into this show where
people think it's going to be just like
the old movie a couple of guys in
dresses in the audience laughing about
that I love for people to come
experience it for themselves for the
understanding of the intention we've put
into it and for the creative team
trusting me to be the voice it was a
moment that had to make me confident in
the work that I was doing and the
message that we were sending we look at
the way that people are treated online
are you in a bubble or do you feel some
of that rage even in New York City I
experience it you do there have been
multiple times recently where I've
simply been on the train in a dress and
the train doors have closed and a young
teenager has banged on the door and
looked at me and been like
what is ooh and made these gestures at
me they triggered something in him that
I'm like you're afraid of my freedom and
the joy that I'm walking in and that's
something for you to go unpack and deal
with for yourself because little do you
know I'm on my way to my Tony nominated
show being effective in my Ministry and
walking in my purpose but for people out
there
going through that
what what do you say to them I mean does
it hurt you I have done the work for
myself and I hope that they will go
unpack and do the work for themselves no
matter how somebody else
compartmentalizes me I will always show
up in the fullness of who I am
so wherever you place me that's where
I'll be I don't expect you to understand
the fullness of that at all times now I
will let you know when you're wrong but
as long as you do it with love and
respect we'll be just fine you'll
respond with love and respect always
there's a lot of Grace in that attitude
from you is that something you get from
your family yeah
I'm grateful to my mom my entire life it
may not have always made sense my
choices Who I Am the things that I do
but she's always said well that's your
life go okay she is my date I couldn't
and wouldn't be here in this moment
without her this beautiful black woman
who was a part of some of the first
integrated schools in North Carolina and
to see that her child is making a
difference in the world in this way is
like
see Mom the world is changing and you
have played a part in that I need no one
else next to me but you and here I am
doing what you taught me to do
[Music]
oh yeah